hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm about
to Skype with Gator Martin the biggest
trailer reactor out there this is an
honor
I'm kind of nervous actually what if we
don't get along we're always like toe to
toe him and I it's like sometimes he
gets more view sometimes I get more
views it's like a competition man
all right here we go I just told him we
can Skype Alyssa's hearing the room and
me I'm kind of nervous I'm gonna record
this on my phone him and I get the nice
camera
he gets the phone camera I'm gonna call
this video Gator Martin reaction oh my
god he's calling me hello let's see if
you see me now I'm recording this on my
phone by the way this is so awesome
this is awesome dude are you familiar
with the hard down yeah whoa wait like a
month ago
back ok cool cool ya know when I first
started my trailer reactions you're the
first person I ever saw
really yeah I think without you I
wouldn't be doing it yeah no I saw you
and I was like this looks like a lot of
fun and I realized like I'm not exactly
you so I could probably do something
different a little bit yeah no that's
what was cool about it man so without
you I probably wouldn't be doing this
that's awesome this is tripping me out
I'm actually talking to you totally
tripping balls right now I'm saving all
of this all to really old like yeah I'm
shaving you looks good on you man really
facial hair oh yeah I have a lot of
facial hair right now it's funny we're
both at our sets right now I love it
this is like comparable to an Al Pacino
and Robert De Niro first met each other
on the set of heat right yeah and okay I
can't find a video but he made a video
like a 15-second video saying how happy
he is that he how happy he watches my my
video isn't stuffing like that that
makes me feel so often that I can do
that so he's down
he was like oh wow for like my 100th one
there was a kid who actually has cancer
and he said like how much he's like 12
years old he said how much he loves the
channel so I just made the whole episode
about him to hear stuff like that it
really is like the most moving thing in
the world you have the coolest hair by
the way I'm planning on cutting it after
x-men because I want to style my hair
like Wolverine on opening night yeah I'm
gonna shave - we will Foley yeah I want
to I want to ask questions as if we had
a fan base watching us wanna hear us ask
questions like this what's the best
trailer you've seen this year doesn't
have to be just one no you're gonna be
going at top three or something the
amazing spider-man 2 final trailer does
Emma Age Asia trailer Donna the pendant
of a second Charlie yeah yeah absolutely
man
that was so awesome when I've seen that
trailer is it it was so awesome I was
gonna say that the second trailer for
the dawn of the Planet of the Apes was
awesome Thomas awesome no man you got a
lot of a sudden oh wait wait I want to
change something oh wow this happened a
while ago I think I've put my my phone
number on on on Twitter and again like
this happened a while ago but what I
guess one of one of my one of my
subscribers called me and it was kind of
weird because he called me like really
late and as he was but he was with his
girlfriend at the time and they're both
a mini size when I say sorry for my
intro when I say they were laughing so
much nothing that like live on a phone
dings is completely fanning out here is
that a tattoo yeah it says I have two
that one says faith and this one says
love I don't know
Wow that's pretty cool man I don't have
any tattoos I need I need a 1000 I
really want one I want to get a tattoo
of the movie Drive that my sister drew
for me have you seen that movie
yes what hell yeah you're the [ __ ] man
that's awesome yeah today every soul
awesome by the way my friend Alyssa
she's been on the channel a few times
too she did the Transformers one with me
Alyssa get your ass in the frame yeah
that's Alyssa right yeah this is so cool
it's like I'm interviewing Gator Martin
literally I'm on the other side of the
United States I live in Maryland my
first time going over there it was kind
of poignant I was so so tired because
there's a time difference where you have
retired but not my body so whenever my
friends was to look at me because I work
with my friends when we went to
California because we got there kind of
late but because we wanted it to explore
instead of just went straight to sleep
my eyes are tired but not my body so
whenever someone wants to look at me
they were always think I was high blood
shot ready all right are you from
Maryland yes born and raised would you
ever move out to California yeah yeah I
would excuse me for my language so I
said all the time you would [ __ ] Ella
for Nia oh is that what you just said
over the how it moves my ass over that
[ __ ] hate murder is so boring over
here this is like the whole East Coast
is so boring
historical the culture that the United
States sighs we don't have that here we
have this we have where the awesomeness
place that surrounds small awesomeness
that made no sense but I don't know no I
know it does I love California I think
it's [ __ ] awesome I don't care what
she's saying right now yeah get out of
the frame spare the frame
stay out this skater Martin and I God do
you know I forgot was gonna ask you but
it was like a question I've been wanting
to ask for a while now it wasn't a
question does it have to do with waffles
waffles do you like Roscoe
do you like Roscoe's chicken and waffles
because you know people are gonna ask
you that because you're black and I took
fans into the audience
I do love Roscoe's taking a walk oh hell
yeah do you plan on living there in
California yeah have you really uh yeah
well it's gonna be my main base for like
most of my life we're starting to make
short films and stuff now so I want to
eventually move on to like short films
and actual films and TV and stuff so
yeah it's so weird how do you said that
because right now I want to make I'm
gonna start making them come these kids
and I want to shoot my first one on
sight of it oh no way so cool man that's
into bringing a bunch of hot girls on
the show that's like my thing
yeah yeah no she's pretty sexy how is
she 22 I think no you're lying
yo homeboy you know something no yeah
she's really hot man she is really hot I
do things there but I can't I've been
trying to make moves on Alyssa ever
since I met her and it's not working
what the hell my time will come and
eventually I will come you'll see
yeah the ever not wear glasses by the
way no these are my real wet oh damn you
don't have glasses on you look like 10
times more intimidating yeah I'm like
kind of scared of you right now it's
weird you have like a significantly
tougher face when you don't have glasses
oh yeah it's going on YouTube